henry bari senza indietro perché sei una
m pro ma è bene tutti ragazzi pervenute
questo nuovissimo video sono fighters di
dave irvine yourself trovate stesso ma
non ho mai capito e micah grimes mi caga
segano fa questo gioco sono gli stessi
che hanno fatto flop da quel gioco che
avevo giocato qualche giorno fa e quindi
hanno fatto anche se ti fai yourself c'è
qualcuno che corre nella metro lo sento
si vede si sente il fantasma è qui
presente e devo anche prendere questo
pupazzo perché me lo sento che non lo
prendiamo
ricordiamoci ragazze non avete visto
lovecraft dateci un'occhiata perché è
merita parecchio left mouse su internet
parking ticket
eccolo qua meeting with a psico c'è un
meeting con uno psicoterapeuta ne avrò
sicuramente bisogno dopo questo video
c'è qualcosa dice un'ombra madonna
santissima benedette va bene e spunta
non c'è la prima sta cosa rondò perciò
soltanto non c'è il telefono è qua ok no
scusate mi perché non sono molto più
l'iphone shop non sono lo si capì e
allora stai parlando su maturare che
sarà di aldo giovanni e giacomo gli
altri
la vita una mera 81 mostri a long as
vabbè emettono gas silvia in mezzo a noi
ma facciamo più riferimenti a quel gioco
famoso happy meals ma è normale è tutto
questo nome e mi scusi non mi sembra poi
tanto scusa ai carabi anche amato
posizione della della carrozzella da
spingere la carrozzella angela chistu
rumore ragazzi sento group co demonio
oggi sentito un rumore se ne sceso moore
e va bene adesso mi sembra stiamo
fissando un po fuori dal vaso è adesso
tutti calmi che io ci metto un attimo
disinstallare qua e ci mette un attimo
distensione che c'è qualcosa una croce o
meno male si va dai cesti colori mi
ricordano a mob di slip ma ve lo
ricordate uguale o c'è qualcosa qua
mia madre mi ha punito e mi ha chiuso in
una stanza dopo che te ne sei andato
papa ha iniziato a trattarmi molto male
mamma mamma ti prego non fa così
se no qua amici scappa la pipì e vabbè
vabbè c'è chi è allora che cazzo va bene
comunque io non si può fare la vita nel
senso io adesso c'è un fisico da
mantenere una sanità mentale non
rompiamo cile palla vicenda sarà in
grado di trovare una mia se ti segue nel
buio nero parecchio
riprendiamo questo che comunque sempre
madonna di dio
c'è poi sparito ma ruggito nelle
orecchie e poi svanita e va allora coi
tutto solo casino alla fine ho preso il
crocifisso bene sotto l'anno indietro
preferire di crocifisso ci sarà una
storia da seguire il suo gioco sì ma noi
non la capiamo perché siamo occupati a
far rimanere sveglio il nostro cuore un
cras che ti fa ci mette le mani addosso
a me cioè il crocifisso per il potere di
gesù cristo io ti condanno alla
sofferenza suprema nell'inferno c'è
qualcuno là tantum verde
ciao bocca sana porca [ __ ] eva penya
internet bello però ha già visto e cosa
no sempre il classico che il classico
che spegne le luci pian piano dai pirati
girati e puntali la torcia almeno
aspettiamo che aspettiamo all'ultima
puntata della torcia se no perché gioco
di c'è di latta hai fatto bene
sono gli spaventi che sono una mera
calmiamoci un attimo perché questo video
dal vostro pa e allora comunque
complimenti per l'atmosfera ragazzi cioè
nel senso
atto ii non aver paura del buio a mamma
dovremmo cazzo ridi che non sei neanche
tu c'hai la voce in un bambino che erano
capiti e io non ci trovo una minchia da
ridere a 0 proprio tutto
ho bisogno di trovare qualcosa per
aprirle la porta nuova per la cina
catena sta qua grazie alla zia che no 67
queste cose qua un problema minchia io
corro veloce traguardo ancora quale
proprio la cia velocissimo die stadt
site va bene la madonna e 9 corri corri
non posso correre dai tette grosse
togliti è un capito che devo fà non
posso non si toglie non si toglie no
ragazzi orribile a ce l'ho fatta luca
veloce cose tronchesi azzolini non hai
la testa comunque raga mi piace il fatto
che stiamo andando e un gioco in una m
come non detto anche ieri
[Musica]
mamma impazzita con mia mamma questa tu
non sei sveglio vuol dire che sono morto
cosa vuol dire a sono morto che non devo
fare questa cosa barbara finger baro
barba la fim my friends bigfoot salve
bene questa mi mancava l'aria
oddio benedetto santissimo ma che si può
andare lì sopra in uno scenario
giochiamo così tu stai importa io tiro
con trapassa che aprì la porta che palle
se qualcuno e canticchia sa cosa
orribile santo iddio gente che passa io
me ne vado grazie stato bello me ne
possono anche andare se la cosa più
allegra che ho visto dall'inizio del
gioco pensate voglia cos'era quella roba
lì
sono sempre qua
[Musica]
giorno niente find a way to get back a
ok il pupazzo era professore tocchiamo
il pupazzo altre big fun fun
per ora non c'è sta per niente proprio
quindi ragazzi conclude oggi il primo
episodio di find yourself gioco pazzesco
però vabbè non avete ancora vista
seconda parte ed è quella che mi farà
veramente ancora prendere peggio però
per adesso concludiamo con almeno un po
di 200 ansi al giorno ha detto il dottor
non posso fare a 201o sono è è un
disastro mischiate a casa se vi è
piaciuto cosi come non mi piace anche
venuta prescrizione se non sapessi di
schede e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]